foreign
[Music]
with every software engineer's favorite
thing to see uh which is an open GitHub
issue
so the issue that is on the screen right
now is from the flex dashboard GitHub
page
um inflect dashboard is kind of widely
regarded as one of the easiest ways to
get a shiny app dashboard up and running
here the GitHub user is asking how to
make a pretty straightforward app uh
with a dashboard layout that appears to
be tackling this seriously troubling
issue of cookie theft
so the layout is simple there's two rows
uh with the top row having a tab set on
the left and a terribly troubling plot
with an upward trajectory on the right
uh the bottom is a large panel that
bends the entire width um and it's
fairly
gonna be filled with some very
depressing data
but there are a few interesting things
about this screenshot that I want to
draw your attention to
yeah
okay this is better okay so one of the
first things I want to draw your
attention to is that this issue was
opened in May of 2016.
um also known as the before times so
imagine the devastation on cookie
supplies that have been wrought in the
six years that this GitHub user has been
waiting to build this dashboard
so next is below
um which is the thumbs up emoji
responses and there are 18 of them uh
which is by far the most up thumbed
issue on this repo so clearly other
users have been equally troubled by
burglary of a confectionary nature
so why is this issue still open
if we scroll down you can actually see
this is JJ's response which is you can't
actually create this right now
so at this point you might be wondering
why I would dedicate kind of the first
section of my talk uh to pointing out
the shortcomings of software written by
the CEO of the company that I work for
um and really uh I think it's worth it
um because I think it perfectly
encapsulates and motivates the work that
I'm about to show
so if you went to Joe's keynote
um he mentioned this in a similar way
but I I really view Chinese superpower
um as being this Force multiplier as Joe
puts it for data scientists to share
their work to a broader audience
but really there's there's one kind of
pickup in that one kind of hurdle that
we've placed in front of data scientists
uh and using shiny
and to understand what that is I kind of
want to start with a question which is
what is not crucial to doing great data
science
you know there's there's a lot of
correct answers to this question but the
one I'm going for is understanding the
Tangled Parable web of getting the
browser to show what you want
um and where you want it so shiny does a
pretty decent job of this already we
have helper functions but it could be
better
like why did this GitHub uh issue have
to be posted why did this user have
trouble building an app that they could
so clearly draw out
um shouldn't that be enough to create
your app
so more concretely I want to ask the
question of how can we make constructing
the UI of your shiny app take less time
and just generally be more enjoyable
so we want you the data scientists to be
freed up to do data science and not
fiddle with your UI code
and this has really been a big focus of
the China team for a while now and I've
been personally working on it for more
than a year and have come up with two
fairly complementary paths to try to
address this question
so the first one is how do we make
declaring your app layout more
straightforward and intuitive
and the other one is how do we provide a
new way of writing the UI code for your
app
so I'm going to start with the first
question which is how do we make
declaring the layout of your app a
little bit more intuitive and
straightforward
the answer that we're proposing here is
called grid layout
so what is grid layout first and
foremost grid layout is an r package
um and it provides a simple interface
for laying out complex data dashboards
and also it's built on a thing called
CSS grid which is a spec uh CSS belt
built right into your browser there's no
external libraries or JavaScript that
needs to be run to work and also because
it's built into your browser it's not
going to be abandoned the project isn't
going to be left uh and not work late
so how do we actually go about using
grid layout I'm going to give you a
quick example in code
um and so we start by using a grid
layout aware container in this case
we're using grid page we have other
containers for doing like nesting grids
uh or putting them in more traditional
apps so here we're doing grid page which
lays out your entire app page with grid
layout
so after that we Define the layout and
here this is the layout defined it's a
table but the table is represented as a
character Vector where there's two
elements and each element represents a
row of your layout and then each column
of your layout is represented
um as uh basically one or more spaces um
in this one or more spaces rule allows
you to line things up like you see here
so on the top we have two columns that
say tabs next to that we have cookies
and then on the bottom we just have
bottom all the way across
so then to place uh items in this grid
you just use grid card uh it's a
familiar syntax kind of like tab set
panel so here like at the top we use
grid card and we place it in the tabs
area of the layout that we've just
defined using area equals tab we just
have to match each one of those areas to
grid card or friends such as grid card
plot
and this is the output of that exact
code that you just saw
um and it looks pretty similar uh to
something we've already seen which is
the layout that the Fleck dashboard uh
GitHub issue is requesting and so this
kind of feels pretty simple
um but really it covers most of what
grid layout does
um and really grid layout's whole goal
is to be this very simple way I can
think of an app I can draw it uh in a
tech table
um I can make my
okay so that's the first way that we've
tackled this how do we make constructing
the UI tiny app more enjoyable so let's
look at the next way and the next way is
how can we provide a new way of writing
the UI code for your app
and the solution that we're proposing
here called shiny UI editor
so the name may give some of it away and
also uh Joe's keynote yesterday I may
have given some of it away
um but let's quickly clarify what the
shiny UI editor is
the shiny UI editor is a drag and drop
visual editor uh for your shiny app UI
this GIF that you're seeing kind of
demonstrates that uh in pretty concise
form you can drag elements around you
can move them you can resize them and it
builds your UI doing that
and don't worry we're going to show a
little bit more about uh in a few
minutes
the shiny UI editor is also in our
packet um it's not a very interesting r
package there's really one function that
you're going to be using which is launch
editor but that's how you get it you go
just like any other r package install it
that way so you get the shiny UI it
so more philosophically the shiny UI
editor is an attempt to help you focus
on kind of the fun stuff and if you've
ever spent a bunch of time doing things
like you know tweaking a pot size or
making a column slightly bigger but you
know incrementing a pixel value up and
testing it uh you kind of know what I
mean and the UI editor is really an
attempt to make take that away let you
just visually drag it to where you want
it to be and then let the UI editor
write the code for you
so now that we've established kind of
what the UI editor is let's talk about I
think just as importantly what the UI
editor is not
the UI editor is not a new UI framework
it provides like as a visual way of
declaring the UI for your app but it
writes that in whatever framework you
want however we hope that you really
like grid layout right now because
that's the only supported uh layout I
mean this is actually kind of a little
historical Quirk uh that when we started
uh this whole journey we started with
grid layout and then I made a little
visual editor for just editing those
tables and then it was quickly realized
that you know there's more here let's
expand this um but right now if you use
the UI editor you're also using grid
layout but that's going to change
so kind of on the same vein it's not
going to lock you into using it so by
virtue of it just writing code for you
um if you don't want to use it you just
stop using it and you just start editing
your code like you would edit any other
shiny app so maybe your app is too
complex for the visual editor uh and
maybe you just you know are using too
many things that are not supported in it
right now
um that's fine you're not going to have
to go back to the beginning and rewrite
your app grad and we really put a fair
amount of effort into making sure that
the code the editor produces is
human readable
um so this is something that's been
really important to us
and so kind of in a similar vein shiny
UI editor is is not ready for production
but it writes code for you
um but and so like in theory if that
code works and does what you want
go for it but you know it's still very
early it's in this Alpha stage
um you know we just haven't had that
many hands on it um and so we really are
looking forward to having everybody uh
get their hands on it file issues you
know find areas that you would
you find nice about it and what you wish
it could do but don't don't press that
you're gonna go home after this and uh
immediately start using it for your
production app
so
shiny UI editor is also not available
for python so you may have noticed that
uh rstudio Slash uh now pause it and the
shiny team have been making uh inroads
in the python Community but the UI
editor has not
um so this is just for shiny for R right
now
um that being said as both the UI editor
and shiny for python mature uh the goal
is to bring it to 94 python as well
okay so now that we've kind of
established what it is and what it isn't
let's talk about the workflow using the
UI editor
so we start by launching the editor with
that function that we mentioned before
launch editor you point it at your app
location
and this application can exist or it
might not exist um and if it doesn't
exist we'll ask you a few questions and
you can start with template app
um that UI editor friendly
once you've done that the UI editor
spins up a browser window you can use
the visual interface edit your app code
then you close your browser window
um you enjoy the app
um optionally you can rinse and repeat
and I think that this is really
important we're not setting this UI
editor up to be a way that you start
your app and then you go on to never
using it again it can ingest apps that
it wrote and best apps that theory
didn't write
um and then so you can have it kind of
carry you through your whole uh shiny
app development process maybe later on
you need to add a new plot you can do
that with the UI editor
um not just a way of setting up
okay
so that's all good and interesting to
hear a bunch of tech Snippets and we
read about what the UI editor is but
since it's the visual tool I think it's
probably valuable to actually see what
it looks like uh so
I was gonna do a live demo but I was
told
uh oh
there we go
never see
um so we're gonna start here let me
quick so we have a fresh
um our studio project open
um there's nothing in it you can see on
the in the files pane it's pretty small
I apologize for that but there's nothing
uh sitting in there and so we've run
this launch editor uh function and
pointed it to the current APP directory
and it says we can't find an app so we
fill out some templates
um so it says yeah we want to create a
new app from a template
um and so we say yes we do then it asks
us what template we want so we have a
couple templates right now
rewind this
a couple templates so there's geyser
templates
um and then there's this chickweight
template and
I don't know about you guys but I my
very first job was actually as a chicken
farmer before I had this cushy software
developer job
um and so I was not a park ranger at
Yellowstone so I'm not going to use the
geyser app I'm going to do tick weights
um we've seen enough geysers I think
so we choose that check weight it spins
up the UI editor and it this is what we
have and so this is in a browser Tab and
so looking at what we have here we start
we have this element panel uh on the
left you can drag and drop elements from
that into your app then in the middle
there's this kind of app pane it's the
skeleton it's not exactly your app we
have a bow plot there and on the right
we have a properties panel this
properties panel tells you things like
where the element is within your UI tree
and then you also have an app preview so
that app uh main window that you saw
isn't perfect so if you really need to
see what your app like
and so we have two plots on top of each
other here um and maybe we want to put
those plots next to each other so we can
do that just by reaching up and adding a
new column we can drag one of the plots
over and drag one of the plots up now we
have this whole empty row on the bottom
we can just delete that
and so we can check to make sure that
that works and our app is updated kind
of instantly uh to build that new layout
and so from there we might say you know
let's maybe let's shrink this column on
the left and emphasize the line plot
right do that and it automatically up
and so one of the things we might want
to do also is right now the the number
of lines that are shown in that plot is
given via numeric input but maybe we
want to use a slider so we can delete
that element we can drag a slider input
in go to the input ID change it to the
num chick which is what that uh reactive
input is set as then we can go and
change the value so we're going to say
Min 120 and we're going to use step size
of one
and then we can change the label say
number of
then we can go back to the app preview
to see if that works and we can drag it
see yep the app is actively updated
um and it is working so this kind of
workflow going back and forth between
the preview and the editor is what we
envision people doing
so next we might want to change the
title so this chickways right now let's
change it to our studio con 2022 and
we'll left align it so we can see in the
little tiny preview on the bottom that
it updated but I want to emphasize
another point which is the fact that you
can edit the code as well
so we go into the app code that the UI
editor generated for us previously there
was nothing there and what we can see we
can find this our studio conf 2022 and
let's change that
um right in the code so let's make it
pause it
on and
2022 but make sure it's an integer so
we'll add an l
then we save that and we go back in the
UI editor is automatically updated and
so this is really emphasizing that we
have this workflow of you know some
things might be easier to do in the UI
editor and some things might be easier
to do in code and we don't want to hold
you back we want the UI Editor to just
sit there maybe you just want to use it
to resize columns or you know add a new
plot but you want to type your contents
or whatever by hand there's no you can
go back and forth between the code and
the UI editor leave it up and just edit
your app as you go
and so we can just check now to make
sure that that works we can open up the
app that it generated that's the app
that it generated and so it worked good
I'm given that I pre-recorded this demo
that would be pretty bad if it didn't
work
Okay so
okay so quickly I just want to talk
about the philosophy of the UI editor
so one thing that you might be asking at
this point is how do we avoid some of
the common uh pitfalls of no code
Solutions the UI editor is in a way a no
code solution
um and this is something that we were
very careful about when we started
um and I think this like simplest answer
to that is that it's not a no code
editor
um we're fundamentally we're writing
code the UI editor is a visual interface
but everything goes immediately back to
code and vice versa and so really
um I don't think of it as no code I
really think of it as like a fancy auto
complete you know you might be able to
tab complete something and it does what
you want this is essentially doing that
for your UI
and so we also really tried to keep it
as simple as we possibly could
um because one of the things that
happens uh with no code editors is that
code is an extremely uh wonderful medium
for expressing yourself our studio is
really a proponent of the power of code
um and so the problem with that extreme
flexibility is that there's a lot of
solution space that you need to make
available if you really want to fully
explore that and so visually mapping to
that space can be really intense so we
really carefully pulled everything back
to make sure that we just let you edit
your UI code you can move things you can
set some settings we're really not
trying to go crazy and let you do
everything because we found that in a
lot of tools that do that you actually
might as well just learn how to code
instead of some you know esoteric visual
editor because at least then you know
how to code
don't have them uh skill does not work
anywhere else
and so I think the last and most
important part about it is that this is
the shiny UI editor
um and that's that's an important fact
is the UI editor is not the shiny app
editor we're not trying to write your
server code we want you to write that I
think that you're the best person to do
that we want you to as the data
scientist to write your cool thoughts
and your good models and all that stuff
we're just going to make it a little bit
easier for you to build the UI we don't
want you to have to be an expert web
developer
um to create a nice looking layout for
your app
um so the UI editor is the UI edit not
the server editor it's not a full note
code solution that being said there are
um
Solutions out there that are full no
code that write the server code for you
um and there's actually a talk coming up
after this uh that I'm pretty excited to
see it was just that
so that's all of the slides I have
um this is links so if you scan this QR
code it'll take you to a quarto site
that has links for the website and the
GitHub for both grid layout and the
shiny UI editor uh some info on these
slides and some of my links
um I just pushed them all live just
before this so they don't work I'm sorry
but they should work
um and that is all I have for you thank
you so much
foreign
[Music]